I I did learn and researching you you
talked about like studying comedians
while in New York and like seeing
someone like Chris Rock work out a bit
from just saying it or reading it - now
it's seeing it on a special way and you
you talked about being able to watch a
comedian and the right way to actually
study them and we mean learn to
community the right way well you would
watch like a Richard Pryor and like Bill
Cosby and actually studying their moves
as opposed to just listening for the
joke you're actually studying how
they're funny
well you just pick up things from them
like I got look at Richard Pryor and the
first thing that stuck out to me more
than anything was originality and I was
like well Hawaii is the original arms
because he's talking about his life and
then that led to me thinking that you
know realizing probably for the first
time or the early age that every person
is an individual and we've all been
through even though we're all human and
we're all connected we're all the same
that we're all different and then if you
bring the different parts of you onstage
then you won't be sound like everybody
else so so that gave me that you know
watching Richard Pryor because I can't
do characters like he can but I can be
myself like he he was and so rich
watching which part taught me that also
watching Richard Pryor and Bill Cosby
taught me good storytelling and
structure mm-hmm and then I'd watch
other comics and I see that they have
one-liners and then it was easy for me
to write one line is at first to like it
you just get a sentence like or like if
somebody like there were comics that
would like turn facts into jokes like I
had a like so I just started trying to
gather the facts at first like like one
fact was like most car accidents happen
within 10 miles of your home and I'll be
like I haven't been in an accident in
years I just parked 20 miles from home
so you just figure out a way oh you know
like that but then you're like [ __ ] how
many one-liners I need 50 one-liners
right but then I realized oh you just
take the topics and keep tagging them
you know what I mean you just keep
tagging them and then so so like I have
a shark attack joke that was just it's a
bit if you say it's a bit but it was
just one line at first hmm so then I
realized let me just this is more meat
on the bone just circle around it study
look at it and what other thoughts come
to my head from looking at this one line
or this one fact well let me find out
some more [ __ ] about sharks let me let
me let me watch the whole story on the
news and find out more about the story
saw the girls press conference so then I
kind of made jokes about the press
conference and then how I feel about
what what what I would do if I was her
what my reaction would be
and then you just then it becomes a bit
do you have a formula for surveying a
topic where you're like okay let me hit
it from the girls angle let me explore
it from my angle maybe the news's angle
like you have almost like a checklist
you go through when doing that know like
like even like sometimes I turn a tweet
into a bit okay so then I just sometimes
you just come up with a joke sometimes
you see the topic and then you and you
figure out the joke you know what I mean
but once you figure out the joke you
keep looking research the topic one some
more you can Google store for some some
words that your reader word in a
paragraph and that stands out and is
like let me find more to mean and all
that word and then you just keep digging
and then more [ __ ] comes out and then
sometimes if I want to write a joke
about a topic
I'll just vomit I'll just let's write
anything that comes out of my just don't
even think about it just write anything
that comes out about it and then in
there will be something you clear out or
it'll be something and then then you do
it again on that something it is
something and you just had to come up
with a bunch of [ __ ] and is that
something a phrase or a single word
phrase word anything yeah could be a
slang word you know I have a joke about
[ __ ] boy you know he's just a slang word
you know and I just thought about how
different that word meant something else
when I was a kid when I was younger and
what it means now and I'm going to made
a joke about that and it's in a special
yeah yeah cool it's a whole bit
but it grew from you just free writing
about [ __ ] boy finding some funny things
what I was riffling it as a matter fact
I was riffing with Jermaine Fowler like
somebody had called him [ __ ] boy in a
tweet oh and then he he we were at
Westside comedy club in the green room
and uh he read that off and in it then
that just came out and what will you
take note when things pop up how do you
sometimes yeah I write stuff in my phone
so I don't forget it like I used to
think I remember everything and then
after years of not write down anything
not having new material because I would
write down everything or you you can
make the voice record message to
yourself now I have this thing where I
just text to myself I'll do that too
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah so you'll do
free writing are there any other
techniques you'll use in writing there's
yeah I'll use all the techniques I'll
stand in the mirror and go over [ __ ] and
then because you just by yourself you're
free to improvise you're not waiting for
an audience to tell you that the joke is
done so you'll go further than you
normally would in front of a bunch of
people at least I do sit down and write
with either pen or type conversations
like when I first started when you
mentioned about the Burger King thing
mm-hmm
when I first saw once I decided I was
gonna do stand-up I realized where am I
gonna get material from so anything that
I would say to somebody that was funny
and they would laugh I'd write that down
make a note of that and get to use as a
joke you know what I mean and then start
gathering material like that like I
didn't want to waste anything
any idea and then sometimes also when
you're in the middle of doing nothing
like taking a shower washing your car or
just doing like a task material or the
fix for a joke the patch for a joke
would come okay yeah stuff I'm sure to
write it down right what is the success
rate for a joke I've any of you comments
on here who say like one out of twenty
jokes they'll end up keeping